time at one point during the pandemic
nevada had the highest unemployment rate
in the
entire country and now as las vegas
reopens there are thousands of jobs
available at some really good news
hector mejia live outside allegiant
stadium where they're offering jobs
right now good morning hector hey there
alex good morning this is a major step
in our recovery process here we have
allegiance stadium right behind us and
to my right this is allegion stadium's
website on their main page already
flashing their job information
and separately in downtown circa also
hiring they even have an event going on
today
but let's start with the legion stadium
first up to 2200
part-time game day jobs are up for grabs
people should be available to work all
nine las vegas
raiders home games plus other sporting
events including unlv football games
positions in hospitality food service
security customer service and more
applications are open
right now online let's go over to circa
where the resort is expanding its team
adding about a hundred
positions to keep up with the demand
circa hosts its second drive through
hiring event today
from nine a-m to one p-m that's
happening outside at the golden gate
valet area
they're looking for housekeepers guest
room attendants
security and lifeguards they told us
candidates
will be interviewed on the spot so make
sure you are ready
you'll have to fill out an application
either before or right after the
interview
we have those links already available on
our website 8newsnow.com and as we were
just mentioning earlier it's refreshing
news
to talk about this after you've had a
really really rough
last couple of months and really all of
last year reporting live
outside allegion stadium this morning
hector mejia alex
back to you i know it and hector
hopefully soon we'll be able to get into
allegiant stadium
and actually watch a game in person
wouldn't that be nice all right thank
you so much for that good news